через вершину ситуації з неспокійно
донбасі українсько влада знову
заговорила про можеш вивести розміщення
на сході України мою творче і неси він
протекція шанси на тисячу хмари не
шеломи впорайтеся я влетів авдіїв тип
небезпечніше мар'їн кольору прибити
шиї шанси на хмарах не шеломи porsche
адже продумується суть активних
бойових дій shop геть у сировину за
мислилося над розпустою ним своєї місії
на сході України міжнародні
інспектори з вини вид виду то донбас
таза і ви то ще ситуація зі спайку
адже дозволяючи для дітей контингент
багетних салонів
у зону конфлікту сходів усіх старовин
хребтова
на при місії оон потрібно зода
всіх турин протистояння топ то
іллідары ​​у сепаратистів та російську
влада гидка вже дворовий заявляє
що розломи для міжнародних
миротворців україна домагається чи вухо ти
порада у занурення мінських догляд рада
bespeco він алла меблі зі складу
шліфувати диня міжнародну світові творчо
та місії під егідою він souls біля вані та
начебто спк я кай позначаючи характер
топового дружина контенту для теон його
видно заводу у всіх пластиною числа не
ворота базу з Україною та Росією виявиться
двору до цього погладжувала nacl остигає
вона розпуста не місії благ ліпних
шеломів
на донбасі фінансово не загине місії
фінансується що у гуси їх crying I
не він же очевидно і економічного
стану кожна з держав
russian 1 з 10 найбільших спонсорів
апараті він спить ринку та меру
шип відведення тему скво фінансово ти мені за
хибну міжнародну місію на донбасі
харчування majorette вулична від того ж шансу
на розбір таня нових миротворчий він
засіки та на донбасі
обман українці у миротворчих місіях
навесні харчування ще до ефективності цик
місій поклику стане десятиліття
організація образлива гнати її розгорнув
api у сотні миротворчості з Росії 16
9 і da sie zu кремон на кіпр з 64
укосу розум 99 у дірці ти і таких
континентах беруть участь
та й у тисячі українських ризикових служба
всіх